[Music]
good morning Hank it's Monday July 2nd
the first day of the second half of
Brotherhood 2.0 it's also coincidentally
the second day of national finisher
revision of your book I mean seriously
come on month also known by its acronym
NAFA rooibos calm incidentally Hank I
still haven't settled on a title
Hank holy crap you and me and the
nerdfighters raised many many thousands
of dollars for kiva.org over the weekend
hey Hank do you remember in my video on
Thursday when I said that we couldn't
personally open a microfinance bank
because it takes really wealthy people
to open a microfinance bank and so
instead we would have to rely on
kiva.org it turns out that when I said
that I was forgetting about the law of
compound nerdfighting the law of
compound nerdfighting is sort of similar
to the law of compound interest which
Hank I'm sure you remember from when dad
tried to tell us about it a million
times when we were kids as far as I can
remember the law of compound interest
states that you have to put a little bit
of money in the bank when you're a kid
and then by the time you're old it's
become a lot of money and the reason for
that is this very complex fiscal thing
known as magic the law of compound
nerdfighting is similar in that it also
involves magic the law of compound
nerdfighting states that 100
nerdfighters as a group can do things
that 100 nerdfighters as individuals
could not do in this example seen in
this t-shirt that you own Hank we see
that 100 nerdfighters together can beat
up a popular kid by the way Hank I've
been thinking that maybe the opposite of
nerdfighter is decepticon do you like it
what I learned this weekend is that we
actually probably could have started a
microfinance bank if we'd only known
about the law of compound nerdfighting
because people were extremely generous I
mean we have funded a lot of loans now
and over the course of next week we're
going to continue to fund loans and
we're gonna fund loans like crazy we're
gonna help people open bakeries and shoe
stores the other day we helped a guy who
wanted to start a lasso factory a lasso
factory that's so awesome how come I
didn't think of that but there's only
one problem Hank the nerdfighters are
probably getting kind of tapped out what
we need is more nerdfighters Hank I
never really craved more nerdfighters
until this weekend I mean there's plenty
of people out there who aren't
fighters and just don't know about the
term yet Hank what we have is an acute
nerdfighter shortage we got to do
something about this Hank I think
broadly speaking there are four kinds of
people in the world first you have your
Decepticons you know not nerdfighters
then you have your nerdfighters you know
me you Tobias utter all the commenters
all the people who hang out in my pants
all the people who write nerd fighting
songs that kind of thing
then you've got what I like to call your
nerdfighters in training or your knits
your knits or your workers your
occasional viewers that kind of thing
then you've got people who would be
nerdfighters but they don't even know
what a nerdfighter is yet that's very
troubling Hank because those are the
people who could be giving to kiva.org
to pick up where the current
nerdfighters are having to leave off
because they're out of money to lend so
hank what i'm going to propose is a
series of mass promotions first we have
to promote the nerdfighters to being
senior executive nerdfighters then we're
going to promote the knits to being
nerdfighters then we're going to take
all the people who do not yet know that
they are nerdfighters and we are going
to promote them to knit Hank we have to
find a way to tell these people that
their knits and then we have to tell
them to loan money to kiva.org because
the law of compound nerdfighting says it
clearly Hank the more there are of us
the fewer there will be of them I'll see
you tomorrow
Hank speaking of us and then there's an
interesting conversation about
post-colonial theory going on in the
comments that's the kind of thing that
maybe we could talk about in my pants oh
and that's one more difference between
people who aren't nerdfighters and
people who are knits and people who are
nerdfighters people who aren't yet
nerdfighters are like why is that guy
talking about post-colonial theory in
his pains and then people who are knits
are like oh man I should really join
that forum and people who are
nerdfighters are already starting the
thread